welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar from start to
finish biotech nice solutions for bio
processing it is presented by Chris
Hager PhD manager of applications
science at proteins simple which is a
biotech me brand my name is Judy
O'Rourke and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
biotech knee for more information about
our sponsor visit www.hp.com/recycle
inning as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Hager I will
now turn the presentation over to him
thank you this is Chris Hager PhD senior
manager of application scientists and
today I'm here to talk to you about
biotech needs solutions for bio
processing from start to finish
start with a brief set of terminology so
what is bio processor bio processing is
a process that uses a Malian cell line
or bacteria to generate a bio
therapeutic protein trunk
with the bio therapeutic protein drug
it's a number of different proteins
including hormones growth factors as
well as anti-cancer proteins most people
are more familiar with monoclonal
antibodies and amped by drug conjugates
when they think about biotherapeutics
but this also does include both
reference materials as well as the the
widely growing fields of biosimilars and
finally vaccine
shown here is a typical
molecule manufacturing scheme in this
case for aspirin it looks pretty complex
there are a lot of reactors decimals and
steps to make a small molecule like
aspirin
biologics bring significant more
complexity shown here is a relative size
comparison between aspirin and a
monoclonal antibody the antibody is
approximately 800 times the size of
aspirin and is a protein proteins have
post translational modifications such as
glycosylated that impart a significant
potential for variation between batches
of products if the process is not
tightly controlled at all stages
biotherapeutics save and improve lives
as the pace of approvals increase so
does the pressure on makers of these new
biologics to complete their development
processes faster and more efficiently
the one when we look at what the bio
processing industry needs its
improvements in their production
efficiency meaning more speeds better
accuracy through the use of better
technology and they also need to have a
robust supply chain support so that they
can continually make their product
of course at the same time the industry
is always interested in means of cost
reduction and ways to get to market
faster for their given product
biyo technique brands offer the complete
solution for bride bio processing from
start to finish our brands can provide
cell culture media proteins a wide
variety of antibodies small molecules a
large number of different immunoassays
as well as functional assays
instrumentation as well as a variety of
different custom services as we will
discuss today
in addition to having the complete
solution there are a number of key
benefits of choosing biotech need to
support your bio class bio processing
workflow
have access to all products from all
brands including some non catalogue and
developmental materials historical and
current production records for all these
materials the flexibility to develop
molecules and assays for downstream
requirements
we always have regular communication
between groups during the product
development we have a wide selection of
GMP grade molecules and instrumentation
that is 21 CFR part 11 compliant and
finally coordination of bulk orders
across our bands brands and product
lines is important and all this is
designed to help build a more efficient
and reliable process so that you can get
better results in the long run
we have a variety of reagents from
recombinant proteins including enzymes
growth factors in cytokine
we are an industry leader in providing
high quality antibodies with the
capability to develop custom antibodies
specific epitope requirements and can
even generate recombinant versions of
your ass about it in addition we can
provide small molecules and peptides
required for various stages of your
workflow
we are a leader in immunoassays with our
quantity analyzer kit our multi analyze
detection platforms including both
Luminex and simple plex platforms and we
can also support custom immunoassay
needs we also have cell based bio acids
and binding assays to verify the
proteins activity and we can also make
bio assam assays customized to your
needs
lastly we also have a large panel of
enzymatic assays covering everything
from glycosylation to phosphorylation
and again in this instance we can
develop custom and genetic assays to
specifically suit your needs
seeking a little bit more about our
custom services we have extensive
capabilities in both reagent and cell
culture media generation and the
development of both immuno and bioassay
bio technique can provide both
quantities custom formulation all with
the assurance that we have sufficient
production capacity and we are a
reliable supply chain
custom services are run by experienced
dedicated product managers and expert
scientists the custom team can provide
project consultation before you get
started and once the project is underway
we provide documented milestones and
communicate throughout the entire length
of the project so in addition to that
final product we aim to produce at the
end we also provide comprehensive
reports on the custom product to ensure
we've met all the required deliverables
for our protein simple brand we offer a
wide variety of analytical instrument
platforms to support various stages of
the bio process workflow here I'll
introduce them and later I will show you
how they can help solve specific
challenges within the bio processing
workflow
simple Western is an automated multi
capillary based Western blot capable of
separating proteins by either size or
isoelectric focusing by using antibody
based detection simple Westerner can
analyze complex sample types like cell
lysate an immunoassay readout is
achieved by other fluorescents or
chemiluminescence on these platforms
our ice and Maurice platform is an
automated single capillary in a
cartridge platform that utilizes whole
column direct detection by either
absorbance or native fluorescence for
our isoelectric focusing this eye CIF
assay can run up to a hundred samples
per run with separations between six and
ten minutes per sample
in addition Maurice can run te FPS which
allows you to measure the purity of your
final product
these runs take between 25 and 35
minutes per samples and can run up to 48
samples per batch
moving on we also have a single
southwestern instrument named Milo shown
here that performs micro scale
immunoassays and 1000 cells in parallel
Milo quickly separates proteins from
single cell lysate and allows for
multiplexing of up to 12 targets when
paired with the no scan microarray
scanner
our last immunoassay platform symbol
Plex features our Ella instrument but
takes the headaches out of traditional
lives by completely automating the
process simply add samples and buffer to
the cartridge put it inside of the
instrument and hit go Ella can process
up to 72 samples in one hour generating
data with both impressive dynamic ranges
and sub high program sensitivity
particulates are never a good thing
whether they show up during the process
or in the final product
our MFI platform provides an image based
analysis of sub visible particles to
provide not only particle count but also
morphological information the MFI can
differentiate between protein aggregates
silicon oil droplets and even air
bubbles the MFI can run up to 90 samples
per run and has one of the highest
sampling efficiencies of any instrument
in the particle analysis field more
sampling means more statistical accuracy
and better confidence in your data
now that I've provided a brief
introductions biotech these offerings
let's take a look at the bio processing
workflow and how bio technique can help
improve it for you shown here are the
five major steps on bio processing
starting with clone selection and cell
culture development product
characterization followed by a
formulation and stability testing and
final product characterization
these stages can typically be grouped
into upstream as well as downstream
steps
take a closer look at each stage and how
we have helped key customers along the
way
scientists and vaccine analytical
development at merck research labs in
West Point
use simple Western sized assays the
screen clones for their molecules of
interest binary toxin B has a molecular
weight around 95 tailbones and is one of
four protein antigens in the cost radium
difficile vaccine the merck scientist
green seven different clones generated
with baculovirus constructs labeled c1
through c7 in the picture on the right
and we're analyzed for both yield and
product quality cloned for do not
express any product while clones two and
three Express products but a lower than
expected molecular weight suggesting
that the protein was degraded and intact
protein was not present proteins at
higher and lower molecular weight
molecular weights were detected in
chrome five six and seven indicating
increasing aggregation and or
degradation of the product clone one
express the protein at the expected
molecular weight with no degradation or
aggregation observed making it the clear
choice to move forward with further
development
vol technologies including simple
Western provide an average protein
expression understanding of a given
sample
flow cytometry measures single cell
heterogeneity however results are often
confounded by off-target binding or
variants of isoforms that are bound by
the same antibody in contrast milo
performs single cell Western by writing
SDS page separations on approximately
1,000 single cell lysate in parallel and
can distinguish off target binding
events and protein variants and isoforms
enabling verification of cloned
monoclonal T for the first time in the
example shown a few Wells within the
Milo chip have been zoomed in on to
illustrate the power of the technology
and most of the single cells analyze a
single protein in green and the second
protein in blue are observed however in
the last Lane a smaller variant of the
green protein is observed indicating
that the cell population applied to the
single cell Western chip is not
homogeneous this would cause concern and
potentially have go back in the process
to ensure that homogeneous self clones
were produced
once the right clone has been chosen to
move forward with we can support the
growth of the clone with our growth and
production factors we currently have
approximately 50 GMP grade proteins
including lr 3 igf-1 fgf basic and EGF
and an if additional cellular pathways
need to be targeted while growing these
clones we can provide also ion channel
blockers as well as hormone and lastly
to limit a detrimental impact of the
introduced factor we offer both blocking
as well as neutralizing antibodies
we're also making a big splash in cell
therapy or any of these days with our
critical GMP grade small molecules and
protein to give confidence in providing
top-notch quality in this rapidly
expanding field
to grow up your clones you're also going
to need media and supplements we have
you covered there as well specifically
we have specialty serum free media
including chemically defined media that
can be made at a GMP grade level we have
a wide variety antibiotics antifungal
agent often required for culture
maintenance for your larger projects
specific lots of serum can be reserved
in match students for the highest level
of consistency because not all cells
grow floating in media we also sell
basement membrane matrices and purified
extracellular matrix proteins
now let's take a look at how we can help
monitor the cell culture development
process using simple ester here we are
looking at the assessment of antibody
integrity and cell culture samples taken
between days 6 and 14 both under non
reducing and reducing condition
based on these data the culture can be
pulled out of the appropriate day for
subsequent processing we take a look at
these these simple Western images it
appears that day 14 is the best with the
most protein being generated
however if we now look at the charge
heterogeneity of the same antibody
samples shown on the right it becomes
apparent that the material is changing
over this time course specifically the
amount of acidic species is increasing
while the main and basic barians are
decreasing knowing the complete picture
is much more informative as waiting
until day 14 will actually produce a
less desirable antibody product
as we move down into product
characterization the next step is
typically purification shown here with
simple Western is an analysis of a
purification by both total protein shown
on the left with the blue and
immunoassays shown on the right since
the simple ester instruments are
automated and fast quick decisions can
be made about which fractions to include
for pooling and subsequent polishing
steps
the product has been cleaned up it can
also easily be assessed for purity by
maurice using our CES vs mode shown here
is an antibody under both reduced and
non reducing conditions on the left and
right respectively
well it's the new year we've got
something exciting to help bring it in
launching next month is our CES bs+
platform which aims to provide superior
data consistency with a higher number of
objections per cartridge all watt
offering less protein fragmentation
please reach out to your local biotech
the rep or visit our website for more
information
once you've got a relatively relatively
pure product assessing its activity next
on your list with simple Plex we offer
sensitivity great linearity as well as
dynamic range and we have factory
calibrated standard curves built into
our cartridges so you don't have to run
them on the right our two examples for
readouts of growth factor and PDL one
both assays have sensitivity in the low
PI program range with excellent dynamic
range remember these results are
generated in an hour with very little
hands-on time which is way more
efficient than using any other
elijah-like technology on the market
outside of our instrumentation biotech
me also has a wide variety of bio
activity assays to help you understand
your product we have cell proliferation
and adhesion assays apop Tata cafes and
many more we can perform assays for you
if you if we use them to qualify our GMP
gray protein and we can develop and
transfer dozens of other assays for you
to run at your facilities around the
world
shown below or two examples looking at
the inhibition of proliferation by
either a neutralizing compound 2t SLT on
the left or an x adjust on the right
we also offer a number of binding assays
which and we can help develop custom
assays I'll test binding of your product
highlighted as an example let's like to
look let's look at two of our anti ideo
type dance parties
our anti IDEO types are brand-new and we
have them from many of the most popular
therapeutic molecules shown here are
examples of the anti IDEO types for a
diluted lab on the left and to tuckson
AB on the right these anti IDEO type
antibodies were screened again a number
of other bio therapeutic proteins and as
you can see they specifically recognized
their intended target and have minimal
cross reactivity with other therapeutic
proteins tested
not seeing your favorite antibody here
we'll reach out to your local sales are
up and get that conversation started
we're happy to help along this path as
well
okay once you've characterized your
product for activity and other aspects
that we've already discussed the
appropriate formulation and stability
the product needs to be assessed simple
Western can be used to look at purified
samples as well and researchers at BMS
used it to assess heat induced
fragmentation of a monocle antibody over
a three-month treatment at 40 degrees C
increased appearance of 110 kilowatt and
fragment can easily be quantified in an
accurate decision to be made on how best
to store the material similarly maurice
IES can be used to look at VLPs or virus
like protein particles and the best
buffer to keep them stable shown on the
right are three formulations each with
three different trees thawed cycles this
example formulation a is the best for
the VLPs giving the most consistent data
across various freeze long cycles in
either case our platforms can help look
directly at the product and how it
behaves in various formulation and under
various stress condition
an important aspect of understanding of
the formulation and stability is whether
the formulation or storage temperature
impacts the amount of protein aggregates
observed these aggregates are
undesirable even though even it's
dangerous and even dangerous sorry if
introduced into a patient are MFI
technology can easily compare aggregate
numbers and samples produced with
different formulations as shown below
formulation C in this case produces the
fewest number of aggregates and would be
the best case moving forward
lastly the final product needs to be
analyzed for a number of key attributes
bio technique solutions can help with
all aspects of final protein product
characterization including biochemical
assays functional assays it can help
check for excessively low levels of
process residuals like coastal proteins
and again check for particulates as well
as protein aggregates
now let's look at some final products
ice and Maurice are great for looking at
a final pure product shown to the right
is an example of an antibody drug
conjugate the ratio of unconjugated
antibody to conjugated species that
appear to the left of that named peak
can easily be quantified when looking at
this class of molecules the amount of
drug payload on the antibody is quite
important to understand as it directly
relates the efficacy of the drunk
and shown below is another final product
characterization this time on simple
Western for the polysaccharide
conjugated Krim 197 protein found in the
15 gallon PC vaccine
these data help show the level of
conjugated sugar to the protein which is
critical for the vaccines efficacy
in a distance rejecting the
product our MFI technology allows you to
analyze a sample for any additional
unexpected contaminating sub visible
particulates in the storage container MF
I can see silicone oil air bubbles as
well as protein and is easily
distinguished between them
and for the unexpected process
impurities like residual host cell
proteins turn to Ella to help out and
with that I'd like to introduce our
second new product and announcement of
the day we are launching a brand new
cartridge that opens L up to whatever
anodized you'd like to pair into your
automated sandwiched immunoassay
everyone has their own host cell that
they use for growing up their clone and
specific host cell proteins are required
to be monitored along the way with this
new open cartridge researchers will be
able to generate a say on their own
terms with their own specific Cho HCP
antibodies in this example resulting in
an assay with great sensitivity and
dynamic range
provide everything that's needed to be
confident and releasing a product with
sufficiently low levels of
process-related in purity
I would like to conclude by letting you
know that bio technique can perform many
analytical services in-house as well to
characterize your protein biologics we
asked the samples on state-of-the-art
instrumentation using validated SOP and
provide detailed reports for assay
documentation
shown here is a list of the services as
well as the instrumentation that we have
available for this testing
with that I'd like to thank you for your
attention today and hope that you have
enjoyed this webinar please visit our
website for more information on any of
the bio processing solutions that we
have discussed we're here to help you
get your patients better medicine faster
thank you thank you dr. Hager for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank biotech me for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 30th
2019 now the final reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions you
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye